breaking news and this from OPEC this is
news that all of the world markets have
been waiting for and it's most
interesting on the microeconomics of oil
Adam simsky to join us in the next hour
but right now we've got Michael Spen L
Lloyd and Scarlet let's go over these
headlines on both demand ugly and Supply
well the supply is not necessarily
coming from OPEC anymore it's coming
from outside OPEC countries notably the
United States the headline here is OPEC
says 2015 demand for its crude oil will
be the weakest in 12 years years you
talked about tepid demand this is the
weakest demand in 12 years collapsing
demand for opec's oil uh OPEC lowering
its projection for 2015 by about 300,000
barrels a day to 28.9 million a day it's
about 1.15 million a day less than what
they pumped last I'm kind of surprised
to hear OPEC issuing joint press
releases I thought they just disbanded
and went home it's kind of Saudi
Arabia's voice that's what a lot of
people say it's not really Opex on Saudi
Arabia imposing its will upon everyone
else it's SC out the single headline
comes out here and we can address this
with Michael Spence OPEC raises next
year's non OPEC Supply and would be the
United States too where does it have
it oh I I don't know some number that I
can't memorize I mean because even
because the US in 2015 according to Adam
sininsky we're going to have him on
later a million new barrels a day this
is uh Scarlet please no the Bank of
America Marl Ines Francisco blanch was
at a conference yes and what he said was
that uh OPEC has really opinion
dissolved as a cartel Michael Spence do
you agree with
that uh that OPEC is not Saudi Arabia at
the margin are they still the marginal
decider of the price of our oil the
swing
Barrel I think they are but you know I
it looks for the moment like they've
decided not to do it in the way they did
in the past I I mean again to to to the
microeconomics of this which nobody we
don't talk about this enough of
supplying Dem man Brendan mentions the
United States right we have changed the
dialogue of the global economy to the
point of lag guard's new mediocrity
that's absolutely right I mean if you
just stand back from this the United
States is a North America is a is a
major net producer uh and a lot of these
prices were based on you know growth in
Asia that's not going to be as high as
it was I stood in our Washington news
Bureau with Spencer Abraham the day that
the last energy discussion 8 years ago
whatever blew up he was literally in
tears Brendan he was so angry
but then we didn't have an energy policy
and look what happened oil is this one
of these historical moments where people
have to learn how to think about
something in a completely new way we've
always thought about oil in terms of
demand and it's fluctuated with demand
we've always thought about it in terms
of cartel pricing are those just gone do
we need to think about in a completely
new way well if you look at the history
of oil prices the standard argument
would be that they have to go up over
time because of the hoteling argument
basically it's it's an asset but there
was a continuous sequence of positive
Supply shocks and and the latest one is
huge fra we need a trick a trick chart
here this is the dead OPEC bounds no
that's not today although it looks a lot
like it that's
1985 to 1988 and Brendan do your point
of what America's doing this is the
collapse of OPEC and then we just
noodled along for three years I wonder
historically there was a major agreement
in the 20s too over Supply Finds Its
cartel it might not look like OPEC but
it'll look like something in the future
I mean can we assume that that that that
suppliers will figure out a way to price
fix that's part of it but the other part
is that the marginal costs eventually
you know the price will cut through and
and limit Supply on its own on its own
Scarlet uh intraday on West Texas
intermediate we went down an immediate
20 cents maybe 30 cents not the drama
that you'd expect but the intraday chart
off the Bloomberg terminal clearly shows
the weight to oil this morning uh West
Texas down a121 Brent Cruz and you have
to think about it in the context of the
moves over the last couple of months we
had a little bit of a rebound yesterday
but this is really extending its stump
over the last few months I mean I I I I
look at this again as a major headline
to me is non OPEC that the fragility of
Russia right now how do you link oil
prices into the geopolitics of Vladimir
Putin well it'll hurt him badly and it's
pushed him into the arms of the Chinese
because of the geopolitical do you think
that dialogue is ongoing it's a
permanent dialogue literally going back
to what
1970 yeah I I think it is I mean China
has to if China is a net importer they
will benefit uh mightily from this price
decline and they're still concerned
about securing sources of energy Supply
this is the the Thomas Freeman theory
that bad behavior fluctuates with uh
with the price of oil uh but we haven't
seen that that you know he pointed out
that Putin has broken this theorem that
bad behavior actually increased uh with
with with as as the Trice of oil
decreased well he may have thought he
was a little more invulnerable to things
like sanctions than he apparently is now
with a very low price of oil